hi I'm Pete Anton and I'm on set at GQ I
know I'm just as surprised as you are
what is the first call you made after
being hired at SNL weed my girlfriend
initially missed the call from Lauren I
got a callback and I were later and I
walked outside of my bare feet and it
was summer in Austin was just like
hopping around and my feet were burning
and like crying in the streets
my girlfriend cried immediately I called
my mom and I said hey mom I got SNL and
she goes
ha ha ha you're going back to college I
was working on a movie this day and
Dave's like I'm coming with you
I got I gotta get this phone call on
camera and then the phone call happens
so he does not able to get it on camera
but incidentally on the phone it's
Lauren Michaels and he says no we want
you to come out to New York and we want
you to bring your friend Dave - so when
I finally meet up with Dave five minutes
later I'm like hello hey man they want
you to come with me which was pretty
special but I called man
my first call was to my boss at the time
to tell him I would not be coming back
to work and then I think my second call
was to my landlord saying I would be
paying my rent
for more videos like this subscribe to
the GQ channel
[Music]